did you know duet aai in Google Cloud
provides expert assistance across your
entire software development life cycle
from codenation and source citation to
test coverage even designing and
Publishing apis migrating and
modernizing apps and much more with duet
AI developers can use natural language
to quickly understand complex code and
apis and that's only scratching the
surface duet AI can also suggest paths
to help solve your application code
challenges and provide expert guidance
and best practices Direct directly in
your IDE and with Source citations and
Cloud code all those suggestions
provided are automatically flagged to
help you stay compliant with license
requirements and to top it off you don't
even have to know anything about the
world of ML and AI to take advantage of
duet AI not to mention you can rest
assur that your code your inputs and
recommendations remain exclusively yours
and will not be used for any product and
model Learning and Development